[Musique]
le bombardement est intensif les
monstres de poche s'attaque à l'hexagone
figurines montre porte clés car ça ma
gauche hip hop déjà une cinquantaine de
produits dérivés ont envahi le marché au
japon et aux etats unis les jouets
dérivés ont rapporté plus de 30
milliards de francs l'année 2000 et
l'année 2011 sera ok mode tout
simplement parce que au japon nous avons
vu fleurir de nouveaux jeux pokémon gold
et pokémon silver
donc il est très clair que
on a pas fini avec ça ne fait même que
commencer 180 produits dérivés sont
attendus cette année en tête les
peluches et le monopoly pokémon des
réussites commerciales en perspective
qui viendront renforcer le succès déjà
énorme du jeu nintendo qui connaît du
pokémon
à la récréation les pokémon sont le
sujet de discussion chacun y exhibe des
albums de cartes à l'effigié des
créatures les petites bêtes sont très
prisés pokémon tous piégés parce que la
collection de quingey
beaucoup de poster ce que j'ai c'est le
bouquet monsieur gameboy et puis
quelques cartes dont la saga pokémon les
enfants doivent capturer et élever y
entraîner 150 créatures multicolores
pour les faire combattre et devenir
maître pokémon des règles simples qui
permettent à l'enfant de s'affirmer
la dimension excitante de ces règles
c'est qu'elle lui donne vraiment le
sentiment de se rapprocher de cette
inaccessibilité donc un sentiment de
puissance de pouvoir
dresseurs pokémon je vis bien accueilli
six attaques pouvait être aussi efficace
cadeaux vedette du noël 99 les français
découvrent un jeu japonais vieux de
trois ans à grands renforts de moyens
bébé des vidéos distribuées gratuitement
chez les revendeurs le succès de pokémon
n'est pas improviser il était même
prévisible
personne ne semble pouvoir désormais
échapper à l'invasion japonaise de l'est
viator dragon de feu et autres
ectoplasme à ce sont les pokémon qui a
gagné les poches la fièvre pokémon qui a
gagné la poche des écoliers ces petites
cartes à collectionner à la folie font
l'objet de toutes les convoitises et
préoccupe certains responsables
d'établissements au point qu'ils
souhaitent en interdire le trafic dans
leur enceinte virgin ducroquet pierre
mas caisse la folie pokémon dans les
cours de récréation des dizaines
d'enfants agglutinés autour de dizaines
de cartes depuis noël après le japon et
les etats unis les monstres de poche
s'attaque à la france mais le principal
du collège jean jaurès à evreux a décidé
de freiner l'évasion les changes ou le
troc ne suffisait plus aux enfants pour
augmenter leur collection l'argent
entrait dans le collège de mesures ont
été prises aujourd'hui il est interdit
de venir avec toute sa collection et de
vendre des cartes dans la cour les
changes de cartes c'est quelque chose
qu'on a toujours connu dans toutes les
cours de récréation seul ne pose pas de
problème ce qui a commencé à nous poser
des problèmes c'est le moment où on a
découvert que des cartes étaient vendus
et que les sommes qui étaient demandés
pour un certain nombre de ces cartes
étaient des sommes exorbitantes puisque
on a la certitude qu'une carte a été
vendu 100 francs le problème a été réglé
avec les familles et il se dit je crois
que les enfants ont dit tout à l'heure
que certaines auraient pu se vendre 200
francs dans le commerce et les petites
bêtes s'achète 25 francs les 11 ou 75
francs les 60 soit de francs l'unité
dans un paquet il y a une ou deux cartes
rares les plus convoités celle qui fâche
est à la pièce beaucoup plus cher
certains enfants jusqu'à 6 ans carte
écartera qu'on en double c'est bien les
manques comme ça on peut s'acheter plein
de paquets pleins pleins et avoir les
surclassements cher une carte comme ça
mais bon
ça ne l'achètent 200 france ça tourne
autour de 80 si on va la rendre
mais dès qu'on les a tout bon ben on
s'arrête quand on arrête d'acheter
jusqu'à jusqu'à ce que la prochaine
édition en cinquième un enfant sur trois
époques et maniaque tout l'argent de
poche y passe les pokémon c'est un vrai
business
il ya des pokémon voilà en quelques mois
les cours de récréation été
littéralement envahis par ce nouveau
phénomène venu du japon
les enfants en oublierait presque le
traditionnel ballon de foot magique et
des petits personnages comme cela il en
existe plus de 150 les pokémon
abréviation de monstres de poche se
décline sur plusieurs supports carte à
jouer le jeu vidéo ou même plus en fait
quand on a rattrapé un difficile de s'en
séparer
ayrault ceint je les connais tous les
150 ch phénomène de mémoire pour retenir
tous les noms des personnages des
reconnaître on aimerait bien voir ça en
conjugaison
en mathématiques ils ont lu par exemple
il ya squattant bulbeuses eur jpy puff
tuent les hommes 150 prend non et
comment tu sais comment vous savez qu'il
y en a 150 points et bien parce que j'ai
regardé sur un poster puis j'ai vu
stella qui manquait les nouveaux 'plus
reproduise ce que vous voyez à la
télévision et plus battre et faire des
combats rec est en général et quelles
sont les valeurs les plus forts ceux qui
sont les évolués bavure par exemple
évolué soit on attend contre plusieurs
dents il va c'est autant freegan excuses
et dès que quelqu'un gagne
eh ben ils varient un match on peut voir
des choses qu'on qu'ils ne sont pas
réels mais quand même qu'ils sont
amusantes et éducatif pas vraiment
éducatif mais el mil entraînante et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]